With allusions to previous MCU movies and
references to comics that haven't made their
way to the big screen, Avengers: Endgame reminds
Marvel fans that the people behind the camera
are just as enthusiastic as the ones filling
the seats.
Here are some lines in Avengers: Endgame that
were more important than you may have realized.
If you saw Avengers: Endgame in a packed theater,
then the moment Thor's hammer Mjolnir flies
into Captain America's hand probably inspired
one of the loudest and most enthusiastic responses
from the audience.
If not, then it's at least met with enthusiasm
from Thor himself, who yells "I knew it!"
as he spots Cap threatening Thanos with the
legendary weapon.
So what did Thor mean by "I knew it?"
In an early scene in 2015's Avengers: Age
of Ultron, Thor gives the rest of the team
permission to try to lift Mjolnir.
Thor sits back, confident none of his mere
mortal teammates will prove worthy to wield
the hammer… until Steve Rogers gives it
a shot.
That brief nudge, and past comic book stories
in which Cap has proven worthy of Mjolnir,
left some fans theorizing that Cap could've
lifted the hammer but chose not to in order
to spare his teammate any humiliation.
Apparently, the Odinson was one of those fans.
When Thor yells "I knew it!" he betrays that
he thought Cap was faking way back in 2015
as well.
And how couldn't he?
Cap's as worthy as they come.
Speaking of Thor and what he may or may not
be worthy to wield, the thunder god initially
thinks he's the only one capable of using
the new Infinity Gauntlet to bring back everyone
Thanos purged in Avengers: Infinity War.
The team argues about it and eventually it's
the Hulk who convinces everyone he's the only
guy for the job.
As he does, it's made clear he's thinking
about a conversation he had seven years before
with Tony Stark.
In Avengers, as Stark and Bruce Banner look
for a way to track the Tesseract, Downey brings
up Banner's "Other Guy" and compares it to
the Arc Reactor, which at the time was still
the only thing stopping shrapnel in Stark's
chest from killing him.
Banner understands Stark’s suggestion that
the Hulk saved Banner’s life in the gamma
ray explosion, but isn’t totally on board
with the idea.
“It's a nice sentiment.
Saved it for what?
“I guess we'll find out."
In Avengers: Endgame, he finally finds out
what he was saved for.
Explaining that he's the only one who can
wield the Stones and that their radiation
is mostly gamma ...the same as the radiation
that turned him into the Hulk ...Banner says,
quote, "It's like I was made for this."
When Hulk goes back in time to 2012's Battle
of New York, his assignment is to retrieve
the Eye of Agamotto, a.k.a. the Time Stone.
Instead of Doctor Strange, the Hulk finds
the Ancient One waiting for him at the Sanctum
Sanctorum.
Banner and the Ancient One argue over whether
or not it makes sense for her to risk her
own timeline by handing over the Stone.
It's when the Ancient One learns that Strange
gave the Time Stone to Thanos that she changes
her mind.
She tells Banner, quote, "Strange is meant
to be the best of us," as she gives him the
Time Stone, meaning that she realizes her
future student wouldn't surrender the Stone
unless there was a good reason.
Considering what happens in 2016's Doctor
Strange, the Ancient One's reaction is interesting.
Four years from when she calls him "the best
of us," she'll have Strange physically thrown
out of Kamar-taj.
"Teach me …
No."
You could call this a contradiction, but it
could also suggest a lot more complexity to
the early Sorcerer Supreme and her decisions.
Did she expect Strange to eventually show
up and wrestle with the decision of whether
or not to let him in?
Or perhaps ...sensing Mordo's potential for
turning on his allies ...did she kick Strange
out just to see what Mordo's reaction would
be?
Shortly after Tony Stark figures out time
travel, he settles down on a couch with Pepper
and talks about what he should do next.
He tells her that part of him wants scrap
all his work, box it up, and drop it to "the
bottom of the lake."
This is the same Pepper who almost left Tony's
employ in 2008's Iron Man over his armored
adventures and who was ready to break up with
him over his constant "tinkering" in 2013's
Iron Man 3.
"This is a new level of lame!"
She clearly developed a sense of resigned
acceptance since we last saw her, because
her words seem to be what convince Tony to
take his new innovation to the Avengers.
After listening to her husband, Pepper tells
him that trying to stop him has been one of
the few great failures in her life.
It's accurate, as anyone who has seen all
the Iron Man entries can testify, but there's
a bittersweet irony you don't see until the
end of the movie's climactic battle.
After Tony uses the Infinity Stones to wipe
out Thanos and his forces, he collapses and
struggles to hold on to what little life he
has left.
Pepper wills herself to smile at her dying
husband and tells him, quote, "You can rest
now."
And so he does.
Finally and tragically, Pepper gets Tony to
stop.
When Captain America proves himself worthy
of Mjolnir, it isn't the only time in the
final battle that the old soldier has fans
clapping and cheering.
After the heroes Thanos purged in Avengers:
Infinity War finally appear ...along with
the forces of Wakanda, Kamar-taj, and New
Asgard ...Cap takes his place at the head
of this army of resurrected friends.
He leads the charge against Thanos' dark forces
with the line comic book fans have read so
often, "Avengers…
Assemble!"
You may not even realize it until that moment,
but we've been waiting for over ten years
to hear Cap say it.
He may have led the team in 2012's Avengers,
but he never said the line.
He even teased us with it at the close of
Avengers: Age of Ultron.
"Avengers…."
When Cap finally says the line in Endgame
...if you hadn't realized it before ...it
suddenly occurs to you the MCU architects
waited a long time for that line, and man,
was it worth the wait.
It's Emma Fuhrmann playing Scott Lang's daughter
Cassie in Avengers: Endgame ...not the younger
Abby Ryder Fortson, who plays her in Ant-Man
and Ant-Man & The Wasp ...but that doesn't
stop Scott from recognizing her when he returns
from the Quantum Realm.
At the end of their reunion scene, Scott says,
"You're so big!"
It seems fairly obvious ...and it's something
adults say to kids all the time if they haven't
seen them for a bit.
"You’re so big and so well grown."
But it has a double meaning understood by
fans of the comics.
In 2004, the comic book version of Scott Lang
was seemingly one of the fatal victims of
Marvel's Avengers Disassembled event.
In the wake of his death, his daughter becomes
the hero Stature as part of Young Avengers.
Like her father, she has powers that can make
her smaller or bigger.
In a tragic twist, Stature dies just after
her father is brought back to life in 2010's
Avengers: The Children's Crusade.
Thankfully, Cassie rejoins the land of the
living and is reunited with her father in
2015's Avengers World #16 because, you know.
She's a Marvel Comics character, so it's pretty
much mandatory.
After Thanos unleashes his assault on the
Avengers compound, Hawkeye is the first to
get his hands on the new Infinity Gauntlet.
He holds onto the thing for a while, fighting
off a swarm of Outriders and surviving an
attempt to steal it by the 2014 version of
Nebula.
But once the purged heroes return and things
get real, Hawkeye calls for help.
The first hero to respond is Black Panther,
who calls out, "Clint!
Give it to me!"
It's not a particularly memorable line until
you remember how these characters met and
the fact that they only exchanged two lines
of dialogue before Endgame.
In particular, their entire conversation was
about Hawkeye's real name and how little it
mattered, so it's kind of funny that's the
name Black Panther uses in Endgame.
In 2016's Captain America: Civil War.. during
the airport battle and shortly after Ant-Man
shocks the other heroes by turning giant instead
of tiny..
T'Challa advances on Hawkeye.
The conversation that follows is short and
to the point.
"We haven’t met yet.
I’m Clint."
"I don’t care."
Apparently, he started caring just a little
more by the time Endgame rolled around.
One of the best action sequences in 2014's
Captain America: The Winter Soldier is the
tense and eventually violent elevator scene,
as S.H.I.E.L.D. operatives ...who are actually
Hydra agents ...slowly fill an elevator Steve
Rogers is taking, and the old soldier soon
realizes he's walked into a death trap.
Avengers: Endgame gives fans a scene acting
as both sequel and prequel, as it takes place
moments after Loki's capture in 2012's Avengers.
S.H.I.E.L.D. agents are transporting Loki's
scepter when the Captain America from the
future intercepts them in the elevator.
He's able to convince them to hand over the
scepter when he whispers, "Hail Hydra."
The line references the Marvel Comics storyline
that introduced a version of Captain America
who was secretly serving Hydra.
This was extremely controversial, and Captain
America: Steve Rogers writer Nick Spencer
received death threats over it.
Hydra Cap is eventually defeated at the end
of the 2017 line-wide event Secret Empire.
Endgame also echoes that series when ...shortly
after getting the scepter ...Captain America
2019 is forced to fight his double from 2012,
just as the real Steve Rogers defeated his
Hydra counterpart in Secret Empire.
There are a lot of sad moments in Avengers:
Endgame's resolution, but one of the funniest
involves Thor and the Guardians of the Galaxy.
Boarding the Benatar with a heavy sack, Thor
treats the space-faring crew as old friends.
He slaps Star-Lord on the back and says, "Asgardians
of the Galaxy!
Back together again!"
Thor's reference to "Asgardians of the Galaxy"
is more than silly wordplay.
In 2018, Marvel premiered the comic Asgardians
of the Galaxy, featuring Asgardian characters
on a space quest.
The most recognizable characters to MCU fans
would be Skurge the Executioner, played by
Karl Urban in Thor: Ragnarok, and a younger
version of Loki, who begins the series hidden
in the Destroyer's armor.
There's also Valkyrie, Throg the Frog of Thunder,
and the Thor-like Earth hero Thunderstrike.
Considering that Asgardians of the Galaxy
premiered in the second half of 2018, Thor's
line actually brings up a chicken-and-egg
question of exactly who is referencing whom?
Depending on exactly when the scene was filmed,
is Thor referencing the comic in that scene,
or was the Asgardians of the Galaxy comic
inspired by that line from the script?
Shortly after we see Cap leading his support
group, he visits Black Widow at the Avengers
compound.
He talks with his old friend about moving
on from the purge, telling her:
"I keep telling everybody they should move
on.
Some do… but not us."
Cap's talking about accepting the losses he
and Nat have suffered rather than trying to
find a way to reverse them, but there's a
bittersweet foreshadowing to the line as the
movie continues.
By the time the credits roll, Captain America
and Black Widow are two characters who have
definitely moved on.
Black Widow sacrifices herself to get the
Soul Stone from Vormir, while Steve Rogers
uses his quest to return the Infinity Stones
to recapture the life he lost when he plunged
into the ice in Captain America: The First
Avenger.
If you weren’t already crying, that reveal
most likely triggered a few happy tears.
"Taste it, taste the happy Michael.
Tastes kinda like sad."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Avengers:
Endgame are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.